[music]
>> We'll continue.
Number 16 An-Nahl B.
Number 17
Isra
The night journey. Masha Allah. 92.
Number 18
is Kahf, the cave. Masha Allah. 94.
Number 19 is Mary.
Maryam. Masha Allah.
Number 20 is
the two letter from Quran.
Taha.
Masha Allah. Number 21
is Surah Al-Anbiya.
20 Surahs
three missed out. What is the
percentage?
Out of 40 he did not say three. What is
the percentage? Multiply by two and add
half to it it becomes seven and a half.
92 and a half percent right.
I'm sorry, no one is good in maths here.
No competition means I will not improve.
I only improve when I have competition.
I like competition therefore I improve.
I think I'm not going to improve my
maths in this training program. If
someone is there who can be faster than
me then I have to They are so slow so
why should I press the
you know, turbo. I use the turbo when I
want more power. I don't want power so I
have these people all average. So, I
don't think so I'm going to improve my
maths in this program.
and Surahs and 20 meanings
out of 40 you did not
say three. Not that you said wrong, huh?
In negative testing also you'll get the
same.
You didn't say anything wrong so far.
Not a single wrong.
You did not recollect three out of 40.
Multiply by two and a half. You get
answer of seven and a half percent you
did not recollect. Not that you said
wrong. So, far you have got 92 and a
half percent correct.
Zero wrong.
Seven and a half percent could not
recollect.
Good or bad?
Good.
Not good.
Very good. Very good. Not very good.
Excellent.
If this I should have done I would have
said
not very good. Well, he done it before.
You're doing for the first time
excellent. Alhamdulillah.
Takbir! Allahu Akbar. Takbir! Allahu
Akbar. Takbir! Allahu Akbar. Yes,
brother.
Number 22
is Hajj.
Pilgrimage.
You said it 20 or 21? 21. 20 I heard.
You can say 21 onwards.
20 is Taha. Yes, that you finished. 21?
Number 19 is Maryam.
Number
20 is Taha.
Number 21 is
Anbiya.
Masha Allah. Number 22 is Hajj.
Pilgrimage. Masha Allah. Number 23
is Mu'minun.
Number 24 is An-Nur.
Number 25 is
Al-Furqan.
Allahu Akbar. Masha Allah. TAKBIR!
ALLAHU AKBAR. TAKBIR! ALLAHU AKBAR.
TAKBIR! Allahu Akbar. Out of 50 did not
say three. What is the percentage?
94.
94% he was right. Wrong was zero
percent. Could not recollect six
percent. Good or bad?
Excellent.
You will be shocked that if I take the
test of others
many would be lower than you.
You might word are very specific. I say
many when I say most mean more than 50%.
When I say many it can even be three,
four, five, six.
I take my precaution while answering.
So, no one can trap me. As a die you
should know how to answer.
Now you're in front of Zakir Naik.
Say confidently, no problem.
Idhar mano udhar khao.
Be zero outside be a hero.
Correct?
Truthfully answer. Brother Zamri we know
who was the weakest of the persons
answering.
94% correct.
Wrong is zero. Could not recollect is
six.
He might have given three as for sure.
So, you weren't sleeping. You were
awake.
Only thing you didn't have confidence.
At such time
you have to say the word Insha Allah.
Being
less confident also
is not good. Confidence is good.
Overconfidence is also not good.
Something like you know, excess.
Allah says in the Quran in Surah An-Nisa
chapter 4 verse 171, "Do not commit
excesses in your deen."
Quoting the Quran.
Going to extreme is acceptable. Excess
means beyond the extreme.
So, neither be too overconfident
neither be underconfident. Confident.
Alhamdulillah.
Insha Allah.
Now if I ask you
how is your
homework?
What will the reply be?
How well do you know the homework of the
first 25 Surahs with names?
What will the reply be now?
Good.
Very good. Insha Allah. Insha Allah. Now
you know so you can know without Insha
Allah but normally Insha Allah should be
there.
Insha Allah means if Allah wills you may
memorize very well.
And there was a time I remember I'm
giving my inside story.
Most of the time I don't get the time I
require to revise.
Once when I gave a talk which was very
important
very important talk and I had revised
very well.
One time Alhamdulillah and this is the
time I really did my job well.
Believe me.
When I went on the stage I became blank.
It's only once
it has happened. Twice, once. I'll tell
you something else.
But I became blank on the stage on a
very important topic which was the
largest gathering of my life at that
time. 18,000 people.
About 12 years back.
In January
and believe me I became blank.
And
I did not know what I was saying.
And that was one of the worst
times I ever gave a talk. And that was
the time when I was prepared the most.
I finished the talk.
During question answer time I became
normal
and I answered the questions.
Alhamdulillah.
I could not judge how I spoke. Believe
me. I went blank.
I prayed two rakats. I always pray
before my talk and after for shukrana.
That's my style.
Asking Allah's help.
Two rakats before the talk and after the
talk I prayed to Allah.
I was waiting to see my talk.
When I went back to the editing table
and saw the talk
Alhamdulillah. Summa Alhamdulillah. It
was
excellent.
Believe me I became blank.
And that lecture was
similarities between Islam and Hinduism
at Azad Maidan.
At that time it was the largest
gathering of my life. 18,000.
Allah showed me.
I never was. I always thanked Allah for
my
whatever I'm not worth it.
It has a mean first rate of it.
I always believed it was Allah.
My iman in Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
increased.
Showing me
whatever people say
halas.
With all your ability, with all your
confidence, with all the awards you have
got
within a fraction of a second you can
become zero.
And I know that till today
it's only and only Allah's help and
none.
Getting a crowd of 10,000, 20,000,
100,000, 1 million. It is impossible for
any human being. It's only Allah and
Allah's help alone.
Allah takes you.
He gives you height and if you start
having takabbur
the higher you rise
the harder you fall.
The more high you rise the more humble
you have to be. The more high you rise
the more you have to thank Allah Subhana
Wa Ta'ala. That is the reason Hazrat
Umar may Allah be pleased with him. He
was afraid
that maybe I was that person. The level
of human that he had
other than seeing all that is something
in his heart. He did something wrong and
therefore he's asking.
How you look at the things is important.
Believe me it's Allah's and Allah's help
alone.
Did you ever think before I took your
test
you would be 94% right?
No. You couldn't have dreamt of all of
it, correct?
Maybe you're thinking oh Zakir is being
too tough with me. I'm asking you a
question.
Be very truthful in your answer. Did you
think I was too harsh to him or not?
Yeah, who thought I was too harsh to
him? Raise your hand.
1 2 3 4
Who thought I was not harsh? Raise your
hand.
See some hands went afterwards. Again.
Who thought that I was being very harsh
to him? Raise your hand.
1 2 3 4 5 6
Up or down?
Huh?
Who thought I was I'm not asking who
thought I was kind, huh?
Who thought I was not harsh to him?
Raise your hand, huh?
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 So fine.
>> [music]
>> Allahu
Allahu
>> [music]
[music]
>> Allahu Allahu ya Rabbi ya Allahu
Allahu ya
Rabbi ya Allahu